AND NOT THEM.
THEY WERE WRONG.
THEY GOT PULITZERS FOR A HOAX.
THANK YOU BOTH.
JOINING US NOW, MORE REACTION
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, PLUS AN
UPDATE ON REOPENING THE COUNTRY,
PLUS SECONDARY -- PLUS SECRETARY
KAYLEIGH McENANY.
I SHOULD SAY CONDOLENCES.
I WOULD NEVER WANT ANYBODY THAT
I LIKE IN THE WORLD TO DEAL WITH
THESE IN THE MEDIA LIKE YOU DO
EVERYDAY.
WHY YOU TOOK THAT JOB JOB I HAVE
NO IDEA, CONGRATULATIONS.
THE SERIOUSNESS OF WHAT THAT
STAKE HERE IS REAL.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.
YEAH, IT IS VERY REAL, SEAN.
THE FACT THAT ON JANUARY 4TH
THERE WERE ABOUT TO CLOSE A CASE
INTO MICHAEL FLYNN, A CASE THAT
SHOULD HAVE NEVER EXISTED
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
WE NOW HAVE SEVERAL OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS ON
RECORD SAYING THAT.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO CLOSE IT IN
THIS OVAL OFFICE DISCUSSION
TAKES PLACE WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA, WHO THE DOJ,
SALLY YATES, LEARNED FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION AND RUNS
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN A PANIC, NOT KNOWING
HOW THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES EVEN KNOWS ABOUT
THIS CONVERSATION AND THEN TO
FIND OUT ALL OF THE UNMASKING,
THERE ARE VERY REAL, VERY
SERIOUS QUESTIONS HERE, THIS WAS
A HUGE INJUSTICE NOT JUST A
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION, BUT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THE NEXT
TIME SUMMARY AND THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA ASKS YOU IF YOU’RE GOING
TO LIE TO THEM, SAY I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU I WILL LIE A LOT
LESS THAN ALL OF YOU IN THIS
ROOM COMBINED.
HOW’S THAT?
FAIR ANSWER?
OKAY, THAT’S WHY WE’LL NEVER BE